un barco vacío y la tristeza de
múltiples familias ucranianas tras la
retoma de gersón el río nieper se
convirtió en la línea que divide las
zonas controladas rusas y ucranianas
pero también una barrera infranqueable
que separa a las familias las
autoridades eliminaron temporalmente la
prohibición de cruces por el río para
permitir las evacuaciones una medida que
revivió las esperanzas de muchos
ucranianos de encontrarse con sus seres
queridos que quedaron en los diferentes
poblados en la otra orilla aún bajo
control ruso
Tendremos que esperar tal vez venga otro
barco la gente dice que ayer solo había
uno
llegó a gerson desde Alemania tenía un
solo objetivo en mente reunirse con su
hija de 10 años después de nueve meses
de ausencia
vine aquí desde Alemania estaba en
Alemania y vine aquí porque quería
llevar a mi hija conmigo sin embargo ya
no puedo llevarla conmigo si al menos
pudiera cruzar el río para llegar ahí
ante la imposibilidad de recibir a sus
familiares a este lado del Río en gersón
muchos desean cruzar en sentido
contrario para ir en búsqueda de sus
familiares una hazaña casi imposible
la situación ahí no es mejor los rusos
están ahí pero yo digo que al menos
moriremos juntos estoy aquí viviendo
sola
la amnistía para permitir las
evacuaciones por el río nieper comenzó
el sábado y culminará el lunes pero en
el segundo día de la medida ningún cruce
había culminado con éxito en medio del
constante ruido de los bombardeos las
familias siguen a la espera de concretar
un anhelado reencuentro